I I don't think people think you can
make money in the thing you like look at
Barbie right now Barbie's back way away
and if you were obsessed with Barbie
three four years ago if you had started
a meaningful podcast an Instagram
account a tick tock there's a percentage
chance that Mattel and Barbie would have
reached out to you in these last six
months or 12 months and paid you 50 000
for a sponsorship if you were the
leading obviously you have to be good at
this everyone who's listening Vayner
Nation how are you I'm really excited
about this episode of the podcast
because anytime you have a guest on the
show that's named Mr squishy you know
it's got to be decent It's gotta be fun
and that's exactly what this is it's
also pretty entrepreneurial I'll let uh
Scott my guests give you a ton about his
journey I want to use this as a as a
double
um uh bubble as I like to call I want to
hit on a couple things one for the
general audience I've been thinking a
lot about
side hustles opportunities the world's
changing it's just very clear that the
way people think about their careers
you're seeing a much more
multi-dimensional aspect where people
think about their core job and then they
think about side hustles or having three
side jobs to represent the job and I
recently posted something in Social
about how much of an Arbitrage there is
for Doc dog walking businesses because
so many people bought the hug store in
covid and how lucrative that you know
opportunity is and it's around a passion
that I think a lot of people have and so
that was fun ever ready within weeks
gotten a lot of emails from people who
are making hundreds of extra dollars a
week and are ecstatic because they love
dogs and I think what Mr squishy Scott
represents in this vending machine
conversation we have is actually a huge
opportunity for a lot of people
listening to the podcast whether they do
it with him
with us him and I and our JB around be
friends we'll get into that or if you
find something else you want to sell I
you know the day I met him I was like oh
my God
you know if the internet was around and
I found him when I was 16 I would have
done this
and so we're going to talk about the
small toys industry I'm going to talk
about at some point in the podcast why
I've teamed up with him uh We've
launched the be friends vending machine
this will Air probably we're probably
going to be in Chicago doing the
national sports card the national
Trading Card convention where we'll have
some vending machine stuff but we've
also talked to a lot of you in the
v-friends community but not in the
broader Gary vaynerchuk garyvee
Community about this opportunity so
we'll be an opportunity for you to reach
out uh Dustin while we're doing this
episode come up with a URL with the
befriends team of where people can email
or not URL and email where people that
are listening that want to take an
opportunity and what we're doing
together with Scott but that's all big
setup for a really fun episode where I
think people are going to learn a whole
bunch so Scott why don't you tell uh the
Vayner Nation who you are what you do
um and we'll go into a little bit of
your entrepreneurial journey and
backstory and then we'll talk about some
of the current opportunities in the
marketplace
well I think I'd like to start by my
life is about play Passion persistence
but mostly pet play the side hustle's
always been part of I think everybody's
lifestyle surrounding what I've been
doing uh since I've been in high school
um I started High School writing a book
surprisingly on auctions in Edison New
Jersey now who here remembers or has any
relation to Edison New Jersey
yeah that was where I got my big start
which which was the U.S customs auctions
the government options out of Edison
they were on Route One right
yes
and I got I got you know I'm gonna get
my high school in trouble a little bit I
left high school early to go to these
auctions to buy Goods did you go to
Edison hi or did you go to JP Stevens I
went well I actually went to Morristown
I went to Chester New Jersey I got it
and so you know what what was what was
super fun and super fascinating in
um my my transition from high school to
college was I just continued that hustle
mentality that idea of
okay so I'm buying stuff in high school
I'm reselling it too bad the internet
was not huge back then I I had an AOL
address
um that was super fun but my teachers
figured out what I was doing they were
like you know you're bringing scuba gear
Old Bibles
um you know toy sets you know can we buy
some of them and all of a sudden I
started to get a reputation and uh my
English teacher which I'll be honest
school was not my best area of expertise
but my English teacher came to me and
said hey you should ride a uh a small
pamphlet and this pamphlet turned into a
book and this book actually got
published and so I ran into college with
an published book that was actually
being distributed by Success magazine
and that that leverage that little bit
of Leverage there's just a stepping
stone that constantly gave me this
opportunity to open new doors I love
that
that's the idea of this transition so I
walked into college I'm a freshman I
have this this cool book behind me I was
getting royalties and I wanted a place
to spend the money and so rather than
spend it like typical college students I
wanted to invest it okay
um and so I went two directions what
year was this guy just for painting a
picture 93 understood
it's uh you know it was a while ago and
uh I graduated high school in 94. I mean
we're not you know I'm with you right
now I don't know that seemed very recent
I get where we're getting we're we're
not like in the 2000s graduating class
anymore but understood so you're a
couple years ahead of me understood you
going to college you want to invest in
what do you do
well I run it into an engineer uh at the
end of my freshman year okay and it was
Bob Ferris and he had started a virtual
reality company okay and he needed
investment and he needed some strategic
alliances and I had money at the time I
figured I would invest in his company I
would involve myself from his process
and it was great and so we took the
journey together for the next two to
three years yeah because that was that
was the boom of like technology right
like we were in it yeah and so the
opportunity came
um Disney came knocking and we had a
little technology we've been working on
some scent technology some Aroma
technology and I had a choice I could
stay in school or I could invest
full-time working with uh uh Ferris and
Ferris Productions at the time and so I
made the leap to the disappointment of
my family I dropped out of school and I
jumped in full force and worked full
time for this engineer in this company
we built uh simulators and all of a
sudden uh once Disney came knocking and
they used this technology for some of
their rides some of you might be
familiar it was called Soaring Over
California it's now called soaring but
it has Aromas being released on a
time-based event
um that is the same technology we worked
on and we used as a team and so we
leveraged this
um early into my career with Ferris
there was a a great camaraderie but at
some point I wanted to do my own thing
and so I made the biggest leap of my
life I gave him back all of his stock
for one thing freedom freedom to make
choices freedom to try to do my own
thing
um we left on great terms he got back
most of his company I got my freedom to
build whatever I wanted my first client
was General Motors I built NASCAR
simulators for them full-scale NASCARs
with hydraulics that would give people
the idea of racing on their tracks and
traveled around the nation with it
loved doing these products and we could
spend hours with all the clients and all
the cool Tech that we've built but the
full circle on this is years later
um Bob Ferris calls me up and he goes
hey you want to come to New York I'm
going to be ringing the bell we're going
public I'd like you to stand by my side
it's very nice
the amount of respect
and empathy and what gratitude he gave
to me if that statement
the amount of money gone didn't matter
it was it was the feeling that I had
built something with this gentleman he
gave me the respect of saying I want to
ring a bell with you in New York City
that was priceless I I said to this day
I would still take that moment over the
millions of dollars 100 percent
and so that has been my my series of
experiences over the past few years one
of our clients was even Lego
everybody here loves Lego animations we
were the first company ever to animate
Legos and bring Legos to life
and it was an amazing tour we Lego came
to us and they said okay we've got we're
launching this new series of products
we'd like to animate this in 3D with
Aromas and have you travel around and
one of the coolest things is we travel
on this huge trailer that we'd animated
and brought to the Toys R Us's and the
targets of the world and this activation
was about experiencing if if Legos and
animations could meld together we all
know it does now of course
but the kids the kids would actually
come out and this is what was amazing
about it the kids would actually come
out and visit me with their Lego
creations and that was so heartwarming
to me the fact that these children would
come out and be like oh look what I
built and then I could be like look what
I built and when we would share that
moment and I realized that Fascination I
had the connection I wanted with a
customer I wanted that customer feel
like they were listened to I wanted a
customer to feel even if it was a 10
year old kid showing me his Lego
sculpture it was the coolest thing ever
for 10 months and part of the contract
and Gary you'll appreciate this is I
wanted about 30 000 Legos when I was
done
and I backed my trailer into Connecticut
and have them dump Legos at y because I
wanted to build my conference table out
of Legos
I love it I just thought it would be fun
so I spent the next few months on the
floor building a conference table out of
Legos and and it's that type of
experience that I've carried through two
questions guys I think just to bring a
lot of value to a lot of people that are
listening to this podcast what do you
think
has allowed you to keep the joyful
adolescence part in your life because I
would argue as I continue to go down my
journey of Life professionally and
personally I I wonder
and I I think a lot about why am I
happier than most people and it weighs
on me in a great way one it keeps me
grateful on a 24 7 365. even when I am
dealing with challenges
you know last week was a challenging
week for me personally and
professionally and yet I'm just still
like genuinely happy and so I think
about it a lot because I'm also
a person with a large audience now and
and I'm a good communicator and much
like I have spent the last 15 years
enabling people to find angles in
business and marketing mentally but I I
do find my ability to hold on to my
youth me being childish yes as a good
thing
yes my never fully converting to full
pledge adulthood and holding on to
two to thirty percent I'm not even I
don't know if I've done the work yet to
realize what the number is between the
two and thirty percent that I have in me
but I can tell you whether it's two
let's say it's two or three percent I
have a very funny feeling that that two
or three percent in my mix right now has
a huge impact on my joy and my peace of
mind and honestly my professional
success so I'm jumping in here a little
bit just to bring macro value to because
I know this can impact regardless if
people are listening right now or into
Collectibles IPS entrepreneurship this
can help everyone who's listening
you have a sense of why you've been able
to hold on to this youthful when I hear
a man has a career
you know and decides to take months to
build a conference table out of Legos
that's a level of youthfulness that I
don't even possess so I'm and I know you
a little bit now because we're doing
business together with be friends and
your vending machine business and I find
you to be really likable I really like
you
um and I feel like this has something to
do with it and I'm curious if you've
consciously held on to it subconsciously
or was it subconscious and then it
became conscious and you've doubled down
on it break this down because I think we
can change a person's life right now
passion you look at it directly at
passion what do you do on your off time
what do you do that you love do you do
you love sneakers do you love building
do you love helping people do you love
playing do you like changing people's
lives do you like coaching
whatever your passion is whatever you
spend you're off time the time that is
most valuable we all have the 24 hours
in a day but what do you spend when you
have the most valuable resource at your
fingertips where do you spend it is it
social media that's fine is it playing
with toys
social media what are you consuming like
people like I you know you're talking
about I mean my first book was lit I
mean literally this little book right
there is literally passion on your
passion so you can imagine I'm excited
and surprised by your answer like
you know I I don't think people think
you can make money in the thing you like
I I think of people who like to Thrift
in Brooklyn
on on San Francisco and all these Austin
on the weekends realized that they can
make 250 000 a year in profit on
thrifting full-time literally waking up
at seven in the morning on Monday having
breakfast and being ecstatic instead of
going to the office to go to 16
salvation armies and 13 you know other
thrift stores and then can't wait for
Friday because that's estate sales and
can't wait because that's garage sales I
don't think that person realizes that if
they didn't buy just for themselves what
they want to wear to be cool
that they could buy the other 87
t-shirts that are the thrift store that
they're buying for three bucks or seven
bucks and could sell for 29 on what on
on all these platforms right Ari or eBay
or things of that nature I don't think
the thrifter right now listening thinks
or the person that's just fully UPS I
just watched a Ray Romano movie on
Amazon which is really good by the way
something about queens and the movie He
plays a part of a dad who's got this kid
sticks this basketball kid but in it the
dad is clearly obsessed with Rocky like
he just references Rocky the movie
there's a scene in a movie where he puts
in a CD a DVD and he takes out Rocky II
and I as we're sitting here I'm like the
person that's fully immersed in Rocky or
look at Barbie right now Barbie's back
a real way and if you were obsessed with
Barbie three four years ago if you had
started a meaningful podcast an
Instagram account a tick tock there's a
percentage chance that the Barbie movie
company would have Battelle and Barbie
would have reached out to you in these
last six months or 12 months and paid
you 50 000 for a sponsorship if you were
the leading obviously you have to be
good at this everyone who's listening
but I don't think the person that is a
lawyer making 319 or the person that's a
retail store manager making 87 thinks
they can make that same number about
Barbie and I know they can yes they can
yeah and it's it's even more than that
it's it's authenticity so you've got to
mix passion with authenticity if you
take those two together if you're
authentic about what you're talking
about it's not about just the hustle
it's about believing what you're talking
about believing what you're flipping or
what you're invested in I mean you and I
talked briefly on the phone and we had
such a connection such an electric
connection with who we are as people
like just ingrained as individuals
enthusiastic passionate authentic and it
came across on a webcam yes
and and it was just I'm not sure if you
use the term webcam anymore but wait a
day that's 90 guys
that was a fun opportunity I'm sure I
use so many terms don't even get started
me not only do I use ridiculous terms I
can't pronounce 33 of the things I say
so you know I'm right here with you but
I agree with you I think the
authenticity matters but keep going
and and so what I like to look at is and
I've met a lot of people who make a lot
of money who are miserable at their jobs
but they go out every weekend and
they're boating with their friends or
they're going out every weekend and
they're doing wine tastings and I'm like
why don't you do boating why don't you
do wine tastes because the world
believes that you gotta eat [__] Monday
through Friday to then employ the
weekend and by the way this gets into
another reason that school [__] me up
so heavily because I think it's being
taught subconsciously there from
childhood I couldn't agree with you more
the thought of eating [__] Monday
through Friday to be able to enjoy
Saturday and Sunday this is why people
are like we need four-day work weeks
because subconsciously people are like
[__] man between kids and
responsibilities and laundry and other
[__] I can't even enjoy my two [__]
days that I barely get and like the
thought of like like I and by the way
Scott I live this life from K through 12
and even further into college I
understand what it feels like to like
look forward to the weekend or to
Vacations or hoping it's snows we're
hoping I get sick I spent 10 years of my
life hoping I would get sick because it
meant that I could miss school that's
how that's what they wanted the thought
of doing that from 22 years old to 70 is
insane to me miserable it's it's it's
miserable I it's funny for me I like
Mondays I actually look forward to money
money for me is exciting because I'm
raring to go everybody got to relax on
Sunday I let them have their time but
man Monday I can get a little bit I can
get going I can I can figure out what's
going on in my world
Mondays are great it's a start of a week
it's a restart so it's a rekindling of
what I'm trying to do so for me it's
about passion it's about authenticity
it's finding what you spend your time on
and make that monetarily make that part
of your life and by the way unlike if we
were doing this in 1965 and we were at a
conference not on the internet talking
about this today that's practical
meaning everyone's listening right now
like all right you two [__]
Fantasyland guys like [__] you I have a
mortgage I have children I am debt
my big point is in 1967 you're right
like what do you do you get home at
seven and like but in 2023 you get home
at seven and you can either go to the
bar join a softball team watch Netflix
decompress and try to enjoy some part of
your day because you just went six seven
eight ten twelve hours or you can say
[__] I gotta get out of this and if I do
my podcast or my Channel or my side
hustle on you know 8 P.M after I do a
little family time to 10 p.m instead of
playing video games or pool or darts or
watching TV those two three hours Monday
through Friday can add up to 10 hours a
week you do that for a year or two you
might be able to build the thing at
night that gets you off the drug that
you don't during the day
and speaking of family time the idea is
how do you incorp your family into what
you do and for many years I've got two
daughters uh 10 and 10 and five and they
are my world and I love to try to
incorporate different things into what I
do with what well you're fortunate you
sell mini toys and it's cool to them as
you can imagine if somebody's listening
and they do concrete production I'm not
sure that seven-year-old Johnny's gonna
love that but to your point if more
people went into their passion yes in
business it is more likely that going
thrifting or or you know supporting the
podcast on The Muppets like literally I
know today if someone is the most
educated and most passionate listening
right now with the Muppets I'm talking
Kermit the [__] frog
that if they become a Content producer
at scale and do it two hours every night
that a year from now they could be
flabbergasted on the opportunities that
come to them and by the way everybody
who's listening why do I know this this
is a hypothesis for me I've been talking
about this for 15 years I have the
unlimited inbox email receipts from
people unlimited hundreds and hundreds
and now thousands and thousands of
people who are just like who's listening
right now saying this isn't real this
you're some people are Scott you know
some people are listening right now in
their car or walking their dog or
exercising and are even frustrated by us
saying do you realize what's going on in
the world there's a recession there's a
this but this conversation needs to be
had because it's true
happiness and mental health are so key
to my life and I navigate what I do in
the choices I make and who I do business
with because of those things but people
who run out of time so what happens how
do you get to the small toys
I made big toys for a while simulators
General Motors right I've made Toyota
boss simulators
huge big things but the problem was I
was feast in famine
a lot of the times what would happen is
I would build a product for six months
and then I would be waiting for three
months for the cycle of the new client
the new product would come in it'd be
one two three a year and I wanted to
affect more people I wanted to do more
um with the public and the opportunity
came I was at the New York International
Toy Fair
and somebody happened to come into my
booth and they said hey I know you're
building these really cool books I had
transitioned surprisingly into Tech so
you know you're talking books right now
the tech I did was books that come to
life so the whole idea was you read a
book you get your phone you scan the
book and the book comes to life the
dinosaur crawls out the princess waves a
wall what year was that
this was
2005. so when you guys scan phone like
we're not in smartphone area so I'm a
little confused we just started the
transition between mobile webcam to
mobile phone the iPhone had the standard
you know front-facing rear-facing
cameras we were able to now to have
people use a mobile phone there's enough
phones and families they could have
iPads that were available and so we we
thought we were on the cusp of something
big and I I went into it hard I went
into this whole idea of what I call a
digital Frontier part of the the other
business that I run is the idea of how
do you do physical with digital so it
had to be a little bit later though
right because the iPhone came out in
June of 2007.
so we started with webcam in 2005 thank
you because I was confused got it so the
book would do the web got it originally
the book from the scanned it would be
webcam it would be on desktop and then
that was thank you because I was a
little confused keep going and I wanted
to disrupt print media I wanted to
disrupt puzzles charts tattoos stickers
books and love this idea of a digital
bridge between physical products and the
digital need of kids parents want to buy
something digital kids sorry parents how
to buy something physical kids want
something digital it's really hard as a
Christmas gift to open up an app I just
but will a parent buy a book yes if that
book comes with an app will the kids use
the book more yes it's a different type
of Storytelling my favorite part of the
world now as we sit together is again
everyone who's listening I'm jumping in
though you might be frustrated like
don't interrupt Scott or this and that
I'm really trying to bring value we are
really in a digital world this physical
digital combo is so real it's funny
we're talking right now a headline that
caught my attention this morning as I
was walking to work was
um the Oppenheimer whatever the movie
crushed right like 235 million and it's
just like rolling loud went down in
Miami this weekend I saw what happened
at vcon record numbers for the national
Chicago that we're going to this week
like we were in the house for so long
we're so immersed in our digital devices
like it's just very clear not just the
kids but the grown-ups because really
our behaviors with digital and and the
real world are more similar than people
think from Boomers there's plenty of
Boomers sitting at their desktop
computer right now for seven hours
shopping and yelling at each other uh or
supporting each other uh and on on their
desktop computer or laptop so it's just
very clear to me that the the physical
end digital world is like very real in
healthy both are very healthy
and when you can be smart and blend them
together and let them work together it's
really cool earlier if you listen to the
podcast you heard a sound in the
background from my mic it was because my
friend Bridget's here a former Vayner
employee who's like friends with a ton
of people she's just visiting the office
she's decided to sit in I hope when you
were talking about the vending machine I
have one here in the office I
took one and she opened it and I saw her
while you were talking scan the QR code
I wasn't sure if it was working or not
so I took the piece of paper and I did
on my own phone and I was like man
people gonna buy this little toy for 50
cents these be friends toys they're
gonna get the little piece of paper
there's a QR code post covered
pre-covered
I'm getting some sort of very small
percentage of people knowing what to do
with that thing and scanning it post
covet everyone from five to 105 now
knows what to do with the QR code every
you know the amount of kids with an iPad
the amount of parents with an iPhone
being able to scan it goes obviously to
our video on YouTube that combo of
digital and physical is pretty rad
it's it's it's for me I sought back in
early 2005 of where this bridge would be
and we talk about failure a lot I love
failing I failed so much in my career
with so many products I have on a shelf
that didn't go anywhere of course but I
have to and I love it I love failing
because it shows me a door that closes
and I need to do something that opens
you also you also tried do you know many
people that also were yelling at us
behind this episode right now like
that's not real also never try
oh I I mean just just for the audience
understand
I I built I think 11 books
15 puzzles five charts tattoos and
stickers and it failed miserably the
public was not ready
yeah too early the webcam thing a lot of
parents didn't know how to use webcams
didn't have enough yet the kids in front
of a computer like it makes sense in
2005 670.
and it still is a hard sell today I mean
we're talking I've been on QVC I've been
on The View and I've tried all of it and
it's just that there's a disconnect
people want right now still today the
book to be a book
um and that's fine I I've this is the
transition to the squishy toys and so I
realized okay how do I find a platform
that works and at the show at the New
York uh International toy fair I was
debuting all these pop our products ran
into a group that had these cute little
pencil Toppers and they had what's
called an mmog a massive multiplayer
online game and they were trying to get
these little pencil Toppers to work on
an mmog and you know it was fascinating
to me because their users and everything
that they were doing with the digital
physical connection was working
um inevitably with what they had I
inevitably bought out their distribution
rights bought out their IP early on and
I transformed that entire product into
what today is squishland and here's some
crazy numbers I know we're on the on the
cusp of of Barbie
um so who do you what do you think is
the most popular best-selling toy ever
of all time all time the most popular
spelling toy of all time is
Slinky the pet rock
um
Mr like
Plato like um uh like what's that thing
the pink stuff anyway go ahead what's
the answer Hot Wheels Hot Wheels four
four billion Hot Wheels have been sold
okay big shout out Mattel what a monster
by the way big shout out for all the
garage sellers listening Hot Wheels Red
Line
just for everybody knows back in the way
back day the Hot Wheels that were sold
the tires had a little red line in the
middle so when I garage sale I can
literally I'm so knowledgeable about
this [__] I can go to a box of Hot
Wheels look at all of them and pull out
the red line Tire ones which are like 50
80 200 bucks a piece that you can buy
them for a quarter at a garage sale and
that's what I love I mean and then look
the next one after Hot Wheels is Barbie
okay so that corresponds with the movie
Barbie sold about a billion Barbies and
now that Barbie you know when they
brought in the new CEO he was very clear
that I'm gonna make this a media company
we've seen it with Transformers and all
that Hasbro's done a good job with that
like you're telling me that we're not
going to see an epic either cars like
Thomas or train like or even Fast and
Furious light Hot Wheels movie in the
next three four years clearly they're
going to do that base on what just
happened with Barbie
and so when you look at like the top 10
toys they're mostly retail toys Barbie
you know since 1959 about a billion you
know same thing with Hot Wheels about 4
billion so the top 10 toys and then you
go down and you get Tamagotchi okay
is again it's a toy we grew up with you
know these things sold about 83 million
pieces and they started in 1996. that
little [__] keychain every girl in my
school had that
and so it it's also about barrier to
entry with a lot of this stuff and so
just to give the audience some type of
grandiose idea between toys and this is
this is kind of how I sometimes
introduce myself I I've made a toy that
most people played with but never really
knew who it was and who made it and
squishland these cute little pencil
Toppers that are you know what we're
making
a squishy
250 million pieces
so and and our success is not based on
being front and center in a retail
Center in Toys R Us our success comes
from vending machines and that's what
that's what everybody needs to
understand is pennies can make sense
okay so vending machines are the first
things you see when you walk through the
door it's the last thing you see walking
out the door it's got the best branding
potential in retail ever
and you may not know this answer and
there may not be an answer or there
might be a number that the industry
throws around at the vending convention
shows but how many stores doors have
vending machines in them with toys or
stickers or such about thirty thousand
yeah it's a lot of locations in the U.S
I know people hear that number and it's
not like a bill you know we're so
accustomed now to hear like a hundred
thousand or a million 30 000 seems small
but it's so many think about what like
things are going let me say it a
different way think about right now
getting in a car and going to 25 stores
now that sounds like a lot so you can
imagine 30 000 stores in America having
these vending machines
that's probably different than candy
right
oh this is just one inch toys so there's
two inch toys there's claw machines
there's stickers there's tattoos
you're talking just one important I see
I see
it's exponential it's
it's the the last census was about a
million heads of Vending in America
a million heads so you go into a toy
store there could be 12 heads in a store
so you're fighting for real estate space
of those 12 heads so what I'm trying to
get at is inventing most people
disregard it but for me it's one of the
best retail centers and nothing in
nothing in vending had been streamlined
everything in vending for years had been
very tchotchke based it was a clear
capsule with a plastic toy inside and so
what I did was I wanted to come around
and say okay I wanted to give people in
the vending industry a retail experience
I wanted them to go and spend their 50
cents their dollar and when they came
out
they bought and they got a fully wrapped
capsule it even had you know all the
warning labels it had your barcode that
you could use and once we did that we
exploded and and Retail came knocking
retail went oh you make these toys I'm
like yes and they're all unique IPS and
so what we tried to do is we disrupted
an industry by increasing the quality
and the standard in which people wanted
to have the experience we knew that the
the people were out there buying
something and so for you and me our
childhood and vending is very sacred it
was the first toy I got to buy with my
own money
yep and then that's that's huge so if
you're gonna to me it's I mean it's also
for every parent that's listening with a
three to seven year old it's like the
greatest gift for you when you're trying
to get some you know errands finish
because for 50 cents or when I was
growing up 25 cents you can keep your
kid busy for the 45 minutes you need
while you're in the supermarket or the
convenience store or what have you right
and that's and you think about it like
whether we're talking about the side
hustle of let's say you like sneakers
well there's a huge industry now of how
to display your sneakers that's only
populated in the last few years these
sneaker walls that are backlit that are
now motorized and then the same thing
goes for the vending there are so many
ways to disrupt these industries and
some we just saw that with threads so
you know even in social media we've got
these opportunities and so what we did
is once this came to this this little
capsule that got wrapped then retail
came and they said hey we'd like you to
have an end cap and so this blue I don't
know what's right there that's it that's
our end cap that's all vending toys that
have been moved into the store that do
so we're inventing and we're in the
store at the same time so we're getting
our IP doubled down before we run out of
time because I want to go into the park
we team up we obviously do v-friends
mini figures together really excited
about it we're kind of launching now
what really caught my attention when we
were talking was the concept of sure
there's a lot of people in my world that
own six stores 15 stores they're the
head of marketing or partnership set a
company that has a thousand stores or
500 so I was really excited about it but
the part that got me really going
was the concept of the people listening
right now that don't have a store could
buy the vending machine and then go to
their local pizza shop or their burger
stop or their bowling alley and get the
vending machine in and share in the
revenue with the place that was the 16
year old me that that was you know full
transparency it was my instant
connection to you because Edison boys
that like never grew up and two
oh [__] because I think we're selling
them for 7.50 oh it's a great price I
mean where people can literally buy it
go to their whatever you know there's
just so many [__] towns in America
and like there's always the cliche like
hot spot that is a one-off and if you go
there and you're like hey Mr Johnson
I'll give you 50 cents on the dollar of
everything here can you just plop this
down and drill it into your the front of
your store that super excites me
well I think I think the idea is
everyone can now have their own little
business and this and this is like a
side side hustle we Supply the machine
the product and you and I are building a
product line this product line is
awesome
I was telling my team about what we've
developed for for you guys because it
has smell and it has glitter it has glow
and has detailed it has all these
amazing pieces that usually I save one
of those for a vending line but you get
them all yeah I mean I come from trading
cards so I need all the Rarities all the
hits all like like it's been crazy to
see some people we obviously previewed
it at vcon uh okay real quick everyone
because we're going to run out of time
uh if you are interested in being a
vendor for the V friends vending
machines email V we're making this very
easy
vfriends.com
b-e-e-friends.com be friends is
b-e-e-f-r-i-e-n-d-s.com so V at
befriends.com and say you have interest
there's 750 bucks a piece then you buy
the little toys make margin on each toy
and uh best of all is the first official
machines going into Wine Library my
dad's store he's very excited about it
he's already he called me it's not crazy
my dad is he's like hey
can I get the rare ones in our machine
can you make like he's gonna lose by the
way on the record why not you're
probably gonna lose money because my
dad's gonna want to support me because
he's the best and probably put it into a
way too important spot in front of the
store where he should have probably put
wine that he can make margin on but I
was like no Dad we can't do that for you
but I'm excited about that uh and I'm
excited that's for me friends but in
general I think this is a viable side
hustle for a lot of people you know just
getting into the vending game either
adding it to the store you own but most
people listening don't own stores being
a middle man and woman buying machines
and then finding locations that have
enough traffic that sell through
specifically places with kids coming
through well I mean it's even more
important if you have kids this is a
great way to teach them how to run a
business yeah I agree you got a 10 year
old daughter who went to a museum and
decided hey we should put them we should
put a a unit there dad why because we go
there almost every summer so we stuck
one of our units up at Bearizona in
Arizona and so we get in free all the
money they make is Theirs to kind of
spend and whatever do whatever they want
to clean the machine it's their business
and so they understand that Logistics of
everything that are going on it's it's
really it's to your point it's really
Lemonade Stand 2.0 no that sounds
awesome but like actually actually
having to sell in a machine to a
grown-up establishment yep
managing inventory and checking on it
every week or you know day or whatever
it is to like be like oh we got to fill
it up
exciting for them no it's they come to
it and they see it dumped out they
collect all the money they put the money
through a coin counter I have here they
get to stack them together we go to the
bank we we get cash I get my cut they
get their cut
I told them I gotta drive them so I I
got a cut of what they were there and
you're running a business here no free
rides kids nobody you know here's the
thing is that even my five-year-old has
a job she picks up all the Squishies on
the floor she gets to keep them but you
know the idea simply is this is a side
hustle that you can do it makes good
money I you you are going to have an
amazing cent of emails over the next few
years of people doing this and they're
going to have great stories for you I
look forward to those heartwarming
stories of parents and their kids stores
doing this so everybody who's listening
obviously there's the befriend thing but
we're gonna sell out of those machines
pretty quickly we may even by the way I
apologize up front we're going to be at
the national where a lot of collector
stores are going to be there we'll
probably get close to sell out of the
machines there so a I apologize if when
you email vfbfriends.com if we're kind
of out be though I'm just one IP Scott's
in the overall business so Scott how do
people find you if they want to explore
more and get educated potentially be a
vendor for your stuff or other stuff or
be a wholesaler or a one-off person
what's the best way to connect with you
well best way to connect with us is uh
one of the one of the sites is brand
vendingproducts.com so that's b-r-a-n-d
vendingproducts.com or squishland I'm
known as Mr squishy if you find me I'll
tell you the story on how I got the
nickname it's incredibly sweet
um it's it's very endearing so far and
what's your email because that's
sometimes the lowest point of friction
s j o c h i m at
brandvendingproducts.com
um connect with me ask me any questions
you've got you couldn't come up with a
longer URL
I mean brand vending but listen trust me
I'm a mess too like I've made the
mistake too but like you know Scott
maybe we can like really crush this fee
friends thing together and maybe maybe
go buy a three letter demand domain at
bvp.com because I'm I mean I would
misspell brand vending
you know what at the end of the day I
could give people my email
I have an AOL address
cooler by the way I'm actually thinking
about getting a Hotmail or AOL address
on some retro like Brooklyn Lancaster
[__] and be like yo I'm
gary.com we're like inches away from
that being the new swag
I love it so come come find me I'll let
you know about Mr squishy and I'll let
you know how we have to buy up every I'm
gonna I think I'm about to buy up a ton
of Hotmail and AOL accounts that are one
name things and like flip them because
these [__] hipsters are gonna get
into this it's so obvious to me yes
100 percent
and so so a lot of side hustles today
you could be in the vending business you
can be in the email retro flipping
business
anyway uh befriends.com if you want to
see we've got a vending part on our
website
um Scott I really appreciate it parting
thoughts I'll give you the last minute
you passionate about what you do be
playful with what you do know that that
family comes first for me but at the end
of the day if you look to your right
someone is more successful and if you
look to your left someone is less
successful you are in the middle you are
okay and you're balanced I love that
brother really good show thank you I'll
see you in Chicago looking forward to
having a lot of fun and uh we'll talk
soon let's go see ya
[Music]